JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Thank you.
It's so great to be here.
I've got to ask you,
like, am I in Googleland?
Like, are you guys
really Googlers?
Because you know you're like
kind of famous out there?
And whether you
realize it or not, you
hold an incredible
amount of influence,
you really do, we're
going to talk about that.
How many of you want to
change your career trajectory
in some way?
Raise your hand.
How many of you want to change
your personal trajectory
in some way?
How about your legacy
trajectory that you
want to leave in some way?
And how many of you wouldn't
raise your hands no matter
what I said?
All right, I think
we're pretty good.
So great to be here, thank
Danielle and Stephanie Redish
Hofman, who's actually on
our advisory board for Girls
With Impact, so she's awesome.
DANIELLE: Yeah, she's
a Googler in New York.
So if you don't mind, I'd love
to start when you were young.
This idea that you decided to
go get a job as a motel maid
at the age of 14--
what on Earth inspired you to
do that and to do that job?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
You know, my mom
found herself single
when I was five years old
and she was single with
no formal education--
three little kids, 1, 4, and 5--
and she had to work two
full time jobs as a waitress
to make ends meet.
And that had a
huge impact on me.
And when I was 12
years old riding home
from school one day on my
navy blue Schwinn bike,
I had this epiphany
and it was a vision
that three things became
really clear which
was I wanted my own
financial independence,
I wanted to have a big
impact, and I had this sense
because nobody was there for
my mom that it was all up to me
and I was going to have to pull
myself up by the bootstraps.
So I was really
focused on trying
to make something of myself
and I didn't care what it took.
I wanted to put myself
through college,
and so that was the
job down the road,
and at least I can say I can
make a bed the Holiday Inn way
still to this day.
DANIELLE: That's awesome.
I mean, I completely
resonate with the idea
of financial independence.
That was a very early
driver for me as well.
And as I just mentioned,
I found myself kind
of jumping around trying
to find that thing that's
going to generate interest,
but also have a huge impact,
and also help my pocketbook.
So when you're deciding
to make these shifts,
how do you know when
it's the right time?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yeah,
it's really hard, right?
I mean, sometimes, you're
forced to make a shift
and I hear a lot of
that from some people.
But an interesting
story, I used to work
in California government
for Governor Jerry Brown's
sister, Kathleen Brown.
And she was running for governor
and I was her press secretary
and I had an aha moment.
And I thought, you know, I could
spend the rest of my career
promoting somebody
else's ideas, or I
could develop my own ideas.
And it was a moment where I--
and I think this is really
important for all of you
is to look at the
path you're on.
Is the path you're on can it
get you to where you want to go?
And at that point, I sort
of decided, you know what?
I think I'll be pigeonholed
if I stay in state government
too long.
So I moved into the
financial industry.
And then the other
thing that I think
is really important
in deciding when
do you make that change is
looking at trends and data.
And so kind of fast
forward a little bit.
I was in business school
and working full time
at a large bank
and I was noticing
a lot of data and trends.
And those trends
at the time were
that women were building
wealth, but they were not
going to places like Yahoo
Finance to invest their money.
And so I had an aha and
in short develop this idea
for Women's Financial
Network which
is the first financial
site for women.
My boyfriend at the time,
though, said, you know, Jen?
I mean, it's a really
good idea but like
Charles Shwab could come in
and take you over tomorrow.
And he was sort of
right about that.
But I thought, you know what?
They're not doing it now, I've
got my business plan in hand,
I had started to form a team,
and I was like, you know what?
I'm going to go for it.
And it completely changed
the trajectory of my career.
I was working at a
financial firm at the time
and my boss invites me over for
dinner, whole different thing.
I mean, I felt like
all of a sudden I
had climbed like 10 rungs
up the career ladder.
I ended up doing a book,
becoming Microsoft Money's
spokesperson, it completely
changed my career.
So what I would say is
look at the path you're on.
Is it getting you
where you want to go?
Is it building you the kinds
of skills that you want,
getting you the kind of
connections that you want,
getting you the credibility
that you need to move forward?
And also think about the
data or trends taking place.
I think it's really want
to stay at the forefront.
And then there's little gut
that comes into play there.
DANIELLE: Yep, yep, but
all that can be pretty darn
stressful, right?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: It
can be stressful, yeah.
DANIELLE: They say that,
what, the top stress
makers are getting
married, moving,
and changing your career maybe.
So how do you manage all that?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Well, you
know, it's really tough, right?
I mean, I actually
had an experience
where I adopted a
philosophical approach.
So a long time ago when I worked
for another elected official
as I was coming out
of UCLA, I got a job--
got close to a job as
the assistant press
secretary for then
mayor Tom Bradley of LA,
a very famous mayor.
And they basically
told me I had the job,
and I went back to my
day job, and I'm still
wrapping up college.
And they called me up and
they said, you know what?
Sorry, but the mayor wants
more diversity on the team.
And I actually
completely got it.
I was a woman, but he
wanted really more diversity
and it was kind of OK.
And so I sat back, and
then a couple of months
later I ended up getting,
through the boss at that time
connection, to ultimately
become the press secretary
to Kathleen Brown, Governor
Jerry Brown's sister,
and at the age of 25.
That was an amazing opportunity.
And so I really now
feel-- and some of this
comes from age--
that things happen
at the right time
for a reason and it's
really easy to get impatient.
And so still to this
day, I will force myself
to breathe and say, the time--
when the right opportunity is
there, it's going to happen,
but it's also important to keep
yourself out there and open
to those opportunities.
DANIELLE: Yeah, I mean, you've
done such an amazing job, which
is really evident in your
book where she's interviewed
hundreds of highly,
highly influential people
all over the world.
How did you build your influence
and your personal brand
so that you could
have these interviews
and really gain those
insights and connections?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: So I think
credibility is so important,
especially here in the Valley.
And I saw the power of that
when I worked in government
for Kathleen because they
were sort of considered
the Kennedys of the West
Coast and the media--
and so I saw the
influence of media.
And then when I was starting
to build my first company
and I had just a business
plan in hand, I went to then--
ultimately ended up
meeting with the CEO
of CBS Market Watch,
financial site in town,
and I had this idea.
And a long story short, he
wasn't willing to invest in it,
but he said, why don't you
become our Women And Money
columnist?
And I scratched my
head and I thought,
oh my gosh, another thing to do.
How am I going to do this?
But I thought, you
know, it's going
to give me some credibility.
As I'm out building this
business, I'm going to do that.
And so there's so much
power in credibility,
but the other piece
of it-- there's
a couple of pieces-- is, number
one, is having a niche focus.
Look at yourself
and the expertise
that you have that's
really unique to you
and build off that.
I mean, everybody has that.
And trust me, I've had
to go through exercises
with myself to really think
about what is it that I know.
For me, it's the
nexus of finance,
technology, and women
I would say, right?
It's somewhat unique.
So look at that.
And then the other is
don't underestimate
the power of confidence
because a lot of people,
no matter what level you're at--
you might think, oh,
I'm not good enough.
I can't be talking to a CEO--
I'm not whatever.
But if you don't deliver
a message with confidence,
you're never going
to go anyplace.
You all know something
extremely well.
You wouldn't be here
working if you didn't.
I don't care what area it
is-- content, marketing,
digital data, analytics.
And so when you
present something,
the power of presenting it with
authority and credibility--
it will make all the
difference in your ability
to move forward.
The last thing is that I do--
and I've had to learn this.
I mean, I came from
completely nothing--
is pulling those threads
that build that credibility
foundation for you.
So there have been times
when I'm talking to somebody
or wanting to form a
partnership or whatever
and I built an advisory
board with some name people
to give me that credibility.
So people said, oh yeah,
that's you know-- now
that's interesting to me.
So those are some
ways that you can--
the last thing that's
worth mentioning
is connecting with people
on a personal level.
It doesn't matter who
you're talking to--
CEO, janitor, or whatever,
everybody is a person.
And a good example
is back when I
was building Women's
Financial Network
and wanting to connect with very
influential people to endorse
or whatever, one was Debbie
Fields of Mrs. Fields Cookies.
And the reason she
came back is that she
saw what happened
with her mother,
couldn't even
balance a checkbook,
and she was dealing
with her own daughter.
So that personal
connection, no matter
who you're talking to, pitching,
building relationships, wanting
to form a
partnership-- honestly,
I think it comes down to that
personal connection almost more
than anything.
DANIELLE: Yeah,
that's good advice.
I mean, given that I
came from the news space
and I know how
finicky media can be,
you say it as if it's so easy
to get the attention of media.
But how do you do that?
How did you-- how
do you get someone
to say, yes Jennifer,
we'll have you on CNN?
Or how did you get on Oprah?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
There's really a power
in things building upon things.
So that I also huge
believe in the power of--
boy, there's so
many good examples
and we'll talk about
one a little bit later.
But when something
happens is to build upon--
I mean, a few examples
would be, for example,
when Martha Stewart was
going through her crisis,
I had a really
interesting message.
I said, you know what?
Despite what she
has or has not done,
she has still delivered
products of great value
that everyday people can use.
I think she might
withstand this crisis.
And I went on CNN the next thing
and I was doing live shows.
And the next thing is like
Fox and the other media
are seeing that.
Here in Silicon Valley
when I was here, actually
what happened is I got profiles
in the San Francisco Chronicle
and I had been
thinking about a book.
And the agent said,
you know what?
Now we've got that profile, we
can take it to the publisher.
They like seeing it
because it's credibility.
Oh, and you also have a company.
And then that led to
a lot of other things.
And also, understanding how
to tell a good story helped,
or how to communicate.
In my case, it was educating
people about finances.
So when I started
building this company,
I said, gosh, I want to
help build our brand,
but I don't want to
spend gazillions of money
like a lot of companies
do sometimes, I
think, not so wisely.
And I thought, I'm going
to try to position us
as the authority
on women and money.
You know, I'm not bad on TV, I'm
not great, done a little bit.
I was not as good as a lot
of other people when I tried.
And when I were on, good
enough to be asked back on.
And so all of that created this.
And then what happened?
Then Microsoft then-- because
I was out in the media,
then Microsoft saw
me out there and they
wanted to do a campaign
across the country educating
women about money.
And they came to me and I
worked for them for three years.
DANIELLE: So it
was really finding
that niche, that unique thing,
and then getting the one media
outlet to pick you up, and
then start generating interest
with other outlets once
you use your ability
to pick up a trend,
and then that leads
to so many new opportunities.
I mean, it's really smart.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: And a couple
other things you guys can do--
and I talk about people.
So let's say you have
a particular niche
and you have something
to say because there's so
many interesting
trends going on.
You could write a byline.
You could partner with
somebody of great authority
at another organization
and do a byline,
and then you can
take that byline
and take it to a media outlet.
Truth be told though,
media is a lot harder today
than it was 10 years ago.
DANIELLE: Yeah, especially the
state of everything right now.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
Oh it's so different
to get your message out.
And so I wouldn't discount
some of the big influencers
on social media channels
as well and events.
DANIELLE: So I
think a lot of us--
I don't know if I can speak for
everybody-- but at some point
have been interested
in starting something,
whether that be a nonprofit, or
a company of our own one day,
but making the shift
from a major corporation
to starting your own business
just seems so overwhelming.
How did you make that shift?
How did you-- what was the thing
that sort of helped to you to
make that transition?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yeah, I think
it's really important to have
a plan before you make a leap.
I see people who don't think
through the basic things,
so clearly like
a business plan--
but also what I
mean that I think
can make a difference if
you're going to make a change,
let's say, is to
have a team with you.
I mean, one of the lessons I
learned that led to that book
is don't go it alone.
For too much of my
career, I actually
went it alone and I learned--
and that's again
why did the book.
I learned in looking at really
wealthy people or financially
successful people, whether it's
Mark Zuckerberg or Bill Gates
or Oprah--
you think from the media that
they did it all by themselves,
but they really didn't.
They had a core partner
in there with them,
and then they leveraged their
networks to extend externally.
And by the way, those folks do
leverage their networks more
than other people.
And women tend to not
leverage their networks
and relationships as much
as men, believe it or not.
So in making the
leap, I think one way
to think about it is you want
to build a moat around you
so that you're as in a steady
foundation as possible.
And ways that you can do
that is having a team,
having a deal in hand.
I could give an example too
of when I was at Bank One
actually.
I knew I wanted to
start another venture,
and I had an idea for some
versions of Quicken software,
but a little bit more
simplified for consumers,
and I had started
building this budget kit.
And before I left, l I went
to the credit card division.
I said, you know what?
I'm going to try to
get a deal on hand
to market, distribute my
products through there,
and I did.
So I would leave
with things in place.
I would never
leave-- like if you
need funding for your
venture, I would never
leave without funding in place.
I would try to have a
deal or two in hand.
I would have a core team
and I would make sure
that your team doesn't look
and reflect just like you,
because you want somebody who
can go into those other areas
or bring those other skills
that you don't have, right?
That's the power
of having a team.
So those are a few things--
and then always a plan B.
What if it doesn't work out?
Or what if I decide to stay here
and I'm going to go to China
and take on a role?
And then what if?
A lot of people don't think
and plan through the what if.
I would say how--
if you have spouses or dear
friends, talk that through
so you are really
thinking through, OK,
if something falls apart--
if a leg in the stool falls,
what's my game plan?
DANIELLE: Yeah, I
mean one of the keys
that you mentioned in your
book is make them want it.
And I think here at Google,
we have 20% Projects
and we're trying
constantly to get
everybody interested in
our new product idea.
And of course, with
physical products,
you can get those
out on the market
and you can test them which you
talk a lot about in your book.
But one thing that
I've struggled with
is, what if it's a service?
What if it's something
like consulting?
Then how do you test what
you can offer if it's you
that you're offering?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yeah,
yeah, so that's a good one.
Actually, I've had some friends
from some big companies right
here come to me on
that very issue,
but I'm going to use
Mario as a good example.
So Mario headed up Quicken
money way back in the day, OK?
And he did exactly that.
And I think he did
it the right way.
Ultimately, what his business
is is outsourced web development
in South America.
When you're thinking
about making a change,
particularly in consulting--
because there are so
many people out there.
There are people
leaving McKinsey
to start up consulting
businesses in technology,
right?
That's who you're
going up against.
I would think a few things.
One is, is what you
are delivering really
differentiating?
Is it powerful?
I think Mario had that.
Because you know what he had?
Lower cost, English
speaking, same time zone.
Many people were going to a
lot of other places, right?
So definitely a compelling--
and on top of it,
he knows software development.
He was doing it for Intuit, OK?
So have something-- it's
got to be a compelling.
If you want to stay in
business-- secondly,
I would think about bringing
really powerful people
to your team.
When you have the strength of
the Google name behind you,
it's not nearly as difficult
as a lot of other people.
So I believe in the power
of brand association.
What are some of--
you want to bring
oomph to this team,
like caliber, so that
when you go and you're
pitching business, they go,
God, they've been at Google
and they've been at
McKinsey, whatever.
And oh gosh, they
know data analytics
and they've built these models.
OK, so that's that.
And then I would test the
waters with potential clients.
And I would actually try to have
a client or two ready to go.
And the last is
again have a plan
B. So in your plan,
set some clear goals.
By the first six months,
we need to achieve x and y
for this to make sense for us.
And I've seen the power of
people setting real markers.
Sometimes, we set
like small goals,
but it's recently
with a team of people
and with a big global company
and revenue kind of down.
And this particular team
although on a Saturday had met.
And they're thinking,
yeah, you know,
so what should our
goal be for this year?
Well, it could be [INAUDIBLE].
They said, you know what?
Let's like stretch it .
Let's make 60--
I'm picking the
number, but these
are the range of numbers--
$65 million is our goal.
We're going to go for $65.
They went for $65.
They exceeded it.
The following year, they
in the $100 million plus.
And in the following year,
they're $200 million.
So if they hadn't set those kind
of markers, the following years
they would not have achieved
what they achieved, right?
They wouldn't have.
So it's the power
of thinking big.
I really love the power
of thinking big, even
here at Google.
And in one of my
roles, I remember
thinking I'm going to focus.
And you've all heard
the advice of focusing,
but I was-- it actually
was right before I started
Women's Financial Network.
I was working at another
financial firm, Bank
of America, really
great, loved it.
But I had this idea.
But I also thought, when I
went to that firm, I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to achieve.
I'm going to focus
on two or three
big rocks that are going
to make a difference.
It's really easy to get caught
up in the minutia all day.
It's really easy.
But if you move one or two
big rocks, it gets noticed.
And that goes back to
building your personal brand
and increasing your worth.
And I know you guys have
a chance for projects
here in innovation.
If you led something, your--
DANIELLE: Oh, yeah, we have
a thing here called OKRs.
And I feel like they can always
end up being 50 lines long.
So consolidating that to
just what are the top three
things that you really
want to focus on
is something that I feel
like we all could work on.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
And then stay focused.
Because I ended up
getting a deal--
long story short is this company
has an index like the S&P 500
index but it really
measures the whole market.
Nobody knew about it.
Long story short, it ended
up doing a deal with CNBC
to use it on TV.
I'm not-- and I never
said anything to anybody.
Keep it quiet until
things are buttoned up.
And that was a really big win.
The CEO even years
later remembered that.
So focusing on the
big kills, when
you have the strength of
Google like you all do.
DANIELLE: Yeah, there
was a piece of advice
that you gave in your book--
Maya Angelou was one
of the contributors.
And you had said this is
something that really resonated
with you and gave you
the ability to go out
there and meet anyone.
What was that advice
that you just--
that really stuck with you?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
Wait, her advice?
DANIELLE: Maya Angelou, yeah.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Oh, she
said that people should not
look at themselves no less
than the CEO and no greater
than the babysitter
whom she pays,
but truly an equal person.
And I think maybe
more importantly,
she said that there is a way
that you walk into a room.
It's not that you're so
braggadocios, she said,
but there's a way that
you carry yourself
with some felicity,
some warmth, and people
feel like I can be
OK with this person.
And so the example would be--
and I don't know if some of you
have had it with leaders,
and I've had to learn it,
but it makes you feel kind of
powerful is working with CEOs.
And when you really know
what you're talking about
and you say it with authority--
because they are
looking for good advice
themselves, by the way.
They can't do it all--
they will listen, and they
will then come to rely on you,
and they'll come back.
And so it's like taking a
breath, getting in your power.
And I've used the power
of visualization a lot
in my life, a lot.
We could talk about that, but--
DANIELLE: Yeah, I
mean, I'd actually
love to go there for
a moment, because I
think a lot of people--
and you had mentioned
this in your book-- have
this mantra that they say
to themselves or this
thing that just changes
their entire
presence in a meeting
or while they're talking
to a business leader
or you have that pitch
that you're trying to make.
What is your process
and what tips
can you give to
people to develop what
they can use in those moments?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: So
I'm going to go to--
I'll give you like a
really good example.
So after I sold
my company here, I
was thinking about what
I wanted to do next.
I figured I'd start something
again, wasn't quite sure.
I thought, you know what?
Maybe I'll work at
a large company.
I ended up pitching
Jamie Dimon who was then
the CEO-- is the CEO
of JPMorgan Chase now,
pitching him, exploring
working with him.
He was the CEO of
Bank One at the time.
And I ended up getting
a meeting with him.
And I'm sitting there
like-- and I was prepared.
We'll get to the
tips in a second.
And I was just thinking,
what am I going
to say when I go in there?
But in all honesty,
my suggestions
are-- number one is to
always do your homework
and know something
about the person.
I think there's so
much power in making
a personal connection
with somebody
and you can do that by--
there's a lot can find online.
You can pick up
something in an office
and it can tell you a lot.
You can start from a
conversation from there.
I like to-- when I'm--
somebody recently was
looking for advice.
She was looking for a promotion
in her company actually
and she needs to
sell herself more.
And I said, you know what I
would do is a one pager that
very clearly and
somewhat visually--
not a bunch of text--
crystallizes your brand and
the impact you've had here--
and she did that--
and then go have conversations
with all the key stakeholders.
And she's doing that right now.
So back to my meeting.
I ended up having a one
pager on some specific ideas
to build the business that, of
course, leveraged what I knew.
So that's the other thing.
And then the last is to try
to offer something of value
to somebody when you're
meeting with them.
And it sort of depends
on the situation.
But in a lot of
cases, it can be as
simple as looking on LinkedIn
at the connection points
that you have and having
a conversation where
at some point
you're saying, gosh,
do you know so-and-so at
such and such company?
And they'll say, no.
And you say, well, would you
like me to introduce you?
A lot of people like to do that.
They appreciate that.
And then lastly is you've
picked up some personal things
or things in that meeting
with somebody, anything
from their dislikes
to personal items
to things they share,
remember that or tuck it away
as I do and include something
personal in a follow-up note.
I think it makes
a big difference.
Like, I really liked it when you
said that, it really stood out,
or I think one of
the things that
could help you move the
needle on such and such
that you talked
about was da da da.
It makes a difference
in your ability
to connect with that person, and
then to come back to them later
you need to.
DANIELLE: To get to your
point about how many people
want to leave a legacy,
Jennifer's company
and working with
a bunch of girls
trying to help develop them
into future female leaders.
So what are some of
the things that you
think are critical to developing
in our youth to really propel
women to the top?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
Well, look at-- you
can't open the newspaper without
reading about future of work,
getting everybody ready
for AI and cryptocurrency
and all this stuff,
diversity, talent pipeline.
And it's strange that you know
here we are today and only 6%
of CEOs are women.
So we want to change that.
And oddly, while
there's a lot of stuff
in this STEM and
coding space, when
you look at entrepreneurship
or business,
there isn't anything that
equips teen girls in this case
to actually build those skills.
And so over 12 weeks, they
go through a mini-MBA,
they do it after school,
we offer it year round,
and they go from ideation
to an actual business plan
and they're launching benches.
We just made-- one of them
made international headlines
a couple of weeks ago.
DANIELLE: That's awesome.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
So we're moving
the needle in their
confidence, in giving them
a leg up, scholarships, but
at the same time allowing
people like you to really--
my hope is that all
of you will join us
in creating the next
generation of real leaders
and playing a role
in that with us
because you can do it
on a personal level.
I mean, there's so many
different ways to be involved,
but it's been
incredibly exciting what
these girls are doing.
DANIELLE: Yeah, yeah
it's really awesome.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: And for
companies like Google too
who are looking to
build a talent pipeline,
this is really important.
And to take what they're
learning at STEM--
you know, they can't take
what they're learning at STEM
or coding if they don't have
the business or entrepreneurship
skills to create
companies and jobs.
DANIELLE: Well, thank you.
I'd now like to
turn the audience.
If anybody has any
questions for Jennifer.
AUDIENCE: So from
Emily in Tech Corners,
sometimes the
power of confidence
of delivery outweighs the
power or expertise or skill.
Have you run into that before?
If so, how do you manage it?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: So I
have been in those roles.
So two things that
I do-- one is there
have been moments where
I've taken somebody's advice
and I just go, get in your
power, and I stand up tall.
One time when I was hosting
some shows, the producer,
the guy said some
advice he had gotten
was to love your audience.
And I think there's
real power in putting
a smile on your face.
It just puts you in the mood.
I think dressing
the role actually
can give you a lot of
confidence, much more
so than you might give credit.
I mean, it has for me.
And the last thing is the
power of visualization.
So I to show kind
of a fun story is
I had a little bit
of TV background.
And when I was
really young, it was
what I thought was a dream job.
But long story short, I end up
getting called by CBS TV in LA
to come in for an audition
tomorrow to be their live money
expert on TV, tomorrow.
And I was like, oh my, God I
haven't done this in a year
and I'm not really that good.
And oh my gosh.
But you know, it'd be cool.
So I get on the phone.
I said, can we do this Thursday?
I'm like, I need to buy time.
I was like, oh my gosh.
And then I just
said, you know what?
Because this was kind
of like my dream.
I said, you are
going to get this.
You are going to get this.
And I just focused and I
was like I am pulling out
the stops to get this, and
I am just going to focus,
and I'm going to deliver.
And I visualized
myself-- and actually,
that little experience I
shared when I was 12 years old,
the epiphany, really was a
visualization about impacting
people on a large scale.
I ended up going
into the station.
I'm next to the TV
anchor I grew up with.
How weird is that, right?
And it's after the morning show.
And they go, OK, let's
do a dry run, Jen,
and let's see if she can do it.
And so we do a dry run.
And they say, OK, tape
is rolling, we're live.
And we do the schtick,
I'm talking about money,
and I was out of the park
and you sort of know that.
So I really think you have
to visualize yourself.
And I've seen this
countless times.
Visualize yourself delivering
it or speaking with authority.
Picture yourself doing that
and then go in and do it.
DANIELLE: Right.
I mean, it's sort of similar to
another theme in the book that
really resonated,
so I'm going to jump
in with one more question.
But you talk about
redefining your comfort zone.
And what I found so interesting
is everybody says, take a leap,
take a leap, just
go do this thing,
but it's not really taking
that big of a leap, right?
You're still-- I'd love to hear
sort of what you're [INAUDIBLE]
because I thought
I was so helpful.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: And so
first off, 45% of millionaires
experienced fear and
2/3 of them though yet
said that they had to move
outside their comfort zones
in order to build their
financial success, right?
It just makes sense.
You can't stay where you are
and get to where you want to go.
You cannot stay where you
are and get to where you want
to go.
You can't, to our friend,
have the expertise
and not deliver it
with confidence.
You're holding yourself back.
Why?
There's nothing to be afraid--
we hold ourselves back.
And so one way when
you're making a change
is to realize you're never
going to something completely
unfamiliar.
You're almost always
leveraging your skill set.
It could be a network
that's around you.
It could be some people that
are working with you that you
worked with before.
There's some familiarity to it.
And then the last
thing is in the book.
There's a story about
[? Trisha Cramer. ?]
She was a schoolteacher
actually, made like $100,000,
but she had this cosmetics
business on the side,
and she wanted to
make the leap, and she
was kind of nervous about it,
and she had a couple of kids,
and she had this aha moment.
She was afraid of losing
her paycheck, right?
It makes sense, right?
And she said, you know, but I'm
actually not really guaranteed
a paycheck.
I have to show up every
day and I have to do it.
And there's lots of ways--
and I just had a conversation
this weekend with a good friend
who has sold two companies,
a woman.
She has a young child, so
she's decided she intentionally
wants to keep
things ramped down,
but her innovative mind has
two other business ideas.
So what she's going
to do is she's
going to prep them to
take to other companies
for them to run
with and she might
get a licensing piece of
it or help them get it
off the ground or something.
Good idea, way of staying
in what she's doing,
but still being able
to maybe see her ideas
come to life which you can
do to some extent at Google.
DANIELLE: Yeah, I
mean getting creative
about the things
you're not great at
and using what you
are great at it.
When looking back at some of the
changes I've made successfully,
it was all things that
weren't huge leaps,
that I was doing something
that I had already
been doing before.
And the that didn't
go so well, I
tried to make too far
of a leap and that's
kind of where things go wrong.
So this was the first
time I'd ever heard
it crystallized in that way.
Any other questions
in the audience?
AUDIENCE: So first and
foremost, thank you
so much for joining us today.
My question is around comfort
zones as we talked about.
When we speak on wealth
generation, people look at that
and they look at
millionaires and billionaires
and think, wow, that must
have taken a long time
or they had a very
innovative idea,
and how did they
get in that space?
What would you say to
people who are looking
to build wealth or become
more financially sound
but see it's so far
off in the distance
that they're kind of stuck
in place, if you will,
like their caution
to move they think,
oh, it's such a long
journey and I have
to do so much to get there?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yeah,
so it's a great question.
I think people--
I've seen people can get
there faster than you think.
So two examples-- big story
over this past weekend
about people who had
become millionaires
in their 30s and they
made a conscious decision
because they wanted to
live a different life.
So they basically didn't
want to be beholden.
And there's so many ways that
you can live below your means.
I did it.
I mean, I was always about
living below your means.
Because every time
you're spending money,
it's going to somebody
else and not yourself
and the power of compounding
that over the years.
There's definitely things
like completely taking
advantage of your 401(k).
Whenever you come
across any kind
of windfall or extra money,
tucking it aside all the time.
I got lucky when
I sold my company.
Well, not lucky I paid
attention is made some money
and really thought about
how I was going to grow it
and I put it in real estate
and tripled it in five--
literally tripled
it in five years.
The other really
interesting story
is that my stepfather found
himself completely out of money
at like about 60.
He had never saved,
generation hadn't learned.
He started his own
business and it
was about to get a contract
with the city of LA.
And long story short,
didn't get that contract,
probably because of some
other political stuff.
And he didn't know what to do.
And I actually ended up
moving in with my parents
and I was actually in
business school at the time.
And I feel like
there was a reason
I was living down in that area.
And he reinvented himself,
which is something
that everybody has to be
continuously at the forefront.
He amazingly learned CAD skills,
all the software, internet.
I mean, here's a guy who is 60
and this was like 10 years ago.
I mean, it was
really impressive.
And then when he had nothing,
so then he ended up getting--
he's an engineer by background.
He's an engineer for
public facilities and stuff
and he ended up getting
hired by a solid construction
company that's been
around many years
and he ended up putting aside
like a half million dollars
in not that long a time.
And they still had a
fairly normal lifestyle.
They had to make a big shift
and a change, but it's OK.
The world makes us feel like
we have to be living large.
I could care less
about having a bigger--
and I don't have a
big house, by the way.
I actually don't
want a bigger house.
But there is some
confidence and freedom
that really comes from
putting it aside and feeling
in control.
And if you're married,
having conversations about--
and I do this very regularly.
In fact, every year
I set my own plan.
I've done this for probably
20 years and I used to do it.
In fact, I wrote it up,
like a buddy system.
But every year at the
beginning of the year,
I always think about
my goals for the year
and I lay them out from a
financial perspective, career,
and personal, including
building friends or networks
because I haven't been doing
that and I know it's important.
I want to share the Alex story
because it's a great one.
So this past weekend, this
friend of mine is at my house.
And I said, gosh, Giselle--
kids are with the kids.
Gosh, Giselle, my husband
and I were kind of talking.
It's very interesting.
We have dinner parties,
we have people over,
but people don't
reciprocate a whole lot.
And she says, you know,
Jen, let me share something.
When I was married to Alex,
and Alex is 49 right now--
nice looking guy, she
works for a hedge fund.
We lived in a 7,000
square foot house.
He made great money.
And I said, Alex, why don't
we have your team over?
Why don't we have
the analysts over?
We have this house.
Like, what are we paying for?
And he just wasn't
comfortable with it.
He was like an introvert.
He lost his job.
It is three years
later and he now
has verbally recognized
the shortfall
of just failing to reach out.
And I want to go to something
about networking too which
is rather than feeling, oh
God, I've got to network,
I've got to do this, I would
take a different twist to it.
I would view it as--
I'm like I just want to have
good impact on the world.
I want to talk to
this person, see
if I can be helpful in some
way and impart what I know.
And by the way, I learn so
much back now from people.
I used to sit on an
airplane and I would maybe
like not be so open,
but you pick up
so much and opening yourself
to the possibilities of what's
around you can take you to
where you want to go, internally
and externally.
DANIELLE: Yeah, I mean--
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: There's
so much more to talk about.
DANIELLE: I know.
What you were saying
earlier totally
reminded me of
mom's advice where
she had said everything
you buy owns a part of you.
And when you said save and
you don't have a large house,
I think that that
constricts you and might
reduce your confidence
to take that step.
So having that safety
net really does impact
your ability to maneuver
in ways because you
know you have a cushion.
AUDIENCE: I just a
very quick question
about identifying your needs.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: About what?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
Identifying your needs,
if you can give us some
guidance about how you did it
and any advice on
that would be helpful.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: If you
know the space you're in--
and I would kind of
imagine all of you
do because you're like in it.
By the way, the best ideas
in business and stuff
come from your experience,
you stumble across something.
So your niche-- for me, it was
I really sort of stepped back.
I have done grids
before, like OK--
but if I were boiling it
down to the three things
that are really me
that are unique--
so I want them to be unique,
compelling, and kind of
at the forefront of where trends
in industry is going, right?
So much now is like data
and AI and automation
and what else people and
talent, I mean, right?
So but there's so many.
Food is going in all
sorts of different places,
crazy different places.
So I would literally
crystallize it
to the words that define
the space that you know
and that you're
good at and that--
where there's value to
be had in the market.
So an overlap between a trend
that's happening and something
that you're really good at?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yes, yes.
Does that makes sense?
And then the other
way to think about it
too is if you were going
to write an article right
now in the New York Times
or the Wall Street Journal
and you were going to like--
what would you write about?
What would the headline be?
And what would you talk about?
And I bet your three
themes should be like--
they'll be floating
in there, right?
DANIELLE: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: I heard you said
you started off as a maid
when you were 14.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: I was.
AUDIENCE: How did you, I
guess, go from that situation
to even knowing to go into real
estate or knowing about stocks?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
That's a really good--
I mean, I feel so blessed today.
I mean, I really--
so when I'm having
my bad days, I
go, God, like, I could have been
in a very different situation.
There's power in
education and that's
why we do Girls With
Impact because I
feel like if I
didn't go to college
and even business
school really changed
my thinking to a whole
more sophisticated level,
changed my income like that
too, for most people it does.
And it changes your ability to
operate with people on a higher
plane, sort of.
You can sort of argue
in business school
there's so much, but--
and I think watching and paying
attention to a lot of people--
So small little example,
I'm just pulling something--
a long time ago, I remember
when I was working in politics
and a lawyer we worked
with and he had written
a book on going to meetings.
And I read that book
and something really
stood with me which is now
whenever I go to a meeting,
I jot down, what do I
want to come away with?
And even if I'm going to get
rejected, which I've been
rejected a gazillion times--
it hurts, but I know
it's going to happen
and I just hope for the best
and prepare for the worst--
is I still try to come out of
something with that meeting.
And that could be a
relationship with them.
Because you know what?
That person has a gazillion
relationships themselves, OK?
And that's happened before.
I met with somebody, a VC
guy, and he introduced me
to somebody else.
It could be that they're going
to introduce you to somebody.
OK, that's great.
By the way, would you-- do
you think there's somebody--
I'm meeting here with folks
about Girls With Impact
and I'm having that
very conversation
because it's a really
small world, like it's
a crazy small
world, and you never
know who you're
going to bump into.
So back to your question,
it's like watching people
wanting to do something bigger.
And it's a combination
of luck I think.
It was also partly,
intentionally looking
at the big picture,
the trends and feeling
like I think we can be an
authority in this space
because I see the trends.
There is no authority
on women and money.
They're making more money.
Everybody cares about women.
They're writing the checks.
By golly, maybe
I have something.
I'm not great, but maybe
it'll be good enough.
And I knew the strategy
of how to come up
with a good story, a good angle.
And so I'd go on and
I was good enough
for that they-- so things
feed on themselves.
And I guess I would say, no
matter where you're going, is--
actually, we talked about this--
is the power of telling a good
story, a good whatever it
is succinctly, not too long,
visually when it makes sense--
the visual identity of Girls
With Impact--
the guy who did that made all
the difference in the world,
like it's the difference between
looking like you have a product
and you're professional
versus something else.
Find somebody if you need to.
Put your best foot forward.
DANIELLE: Yeah, I love that.
So we'll take one more question.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is about skill development.
So when we you want
to grow in our life,
either in the personal
life or in the career,
there's so many skills
that you need to learn.
And then given a time, we don't
have too much time in a day.
So how do we choose
the best skill
that's most important to us?
And how do we
strategize to ensure
that we are not missing out
in some other skill that
may later to be important and
we may end up in some issues?
This is a big issue that I face.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Yeah,
that's a really good--
so how do you develop
the best skill given
that you have limited
time to keep yourself
current and moving forward?
I mean, I'm going to come
back to it more crystal.
But even with Girls With
Impact for me, I was in Davos
and saw the trends and felt
like this also keeps me
personally at the
forefront of innovation
and where things are headed.
So for you, I
would be thinking--
I would be looking at, what
do I actually like doing?
I think you've got
to really like what
you're doing because forget it.
And then I would force
yourself to narrow it down
to three to five of those.
I really like these.
Then I would
probably look at, OK,
where are the trends
going, the skills that
are going to be in demand?
And you could-- you might know
that off the top of your head.
You could look at where Google
is placing money and training
or looking to buy up companies.
That's a way of
doing that, right?
DANIELLE: A company who cares.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: To hardcore
research reports, right?
Or where money is going,
so like cryptocurrency
is a big example.
That would be sort of the other
way I would look at doing it.
And then I would think
like, you could even
have a conversation with
somebody, like seeing could you
apply, could you develop
a skill and apply it
to something that would be of
value here in a new effort?
That's kind of interesting.
Because what does that do?
You build your skill, you
increase your value potentially
here, and you increase kind of
your potential monetary earning
potential, and
then hopefully it's
kind of a skill
that's in demand.
DANIELLE: Yeah, I think
that overlap with here
you really have to
like it is such a key.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW:
I think you do.
You have to really enjoy it.
If you love models--
I've got to share this.
This is great and
then we'll wrap it.
But I had this young woman
from another country who--
it's a great story.
She ended up working for me.
She works for my
husband now and she
has her colleague who
frankly doesn't really
speak much English, OK?
But she is a math wizard.
I mean, they-- and by the
way, the CEO of this company--
it's a division of
a large company,
I mean very sophisticated.
They have seen nothing of what
this girl has pulled together
allowing them to see competitors
and where money is going.
It's unbelievable.
So like for example,
that is a great example.
If you were a genius
in one particular place
and you liked it, I would
explore that and then go
where the future
demand or the trends
are going with things
that we're seeing
and we read about
in the headlines.
DANIELLE: Yeah, double down on
the thing that you're good at.
I've been on so many teams
where other people are
more passionate maybe
in a particular area
and there's no way you
can compete, right?
Because they're talking
to their friends
about that subject
in the evenings,
they're doing something
about it on the weekends,
and here you are just trying to
recover from the week, right?
So having that thing
you're interested in
is so, so helpful.
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: And set a
marker again even for that.
So OK, so it's not going to be
in the next two months maybe,
but over the next year each
quarter I'm going to do x
or I want to get a
certificate in x.
Or if Google is really--
let's just say they
were covering something
or they wanted
something, maybe--
it can make a difference
in putting you
into a different role,
having a certain skill set.
DANIELLE: Yeah, definitely.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
We really appreciate it.
If people here, on the
live stream, or on Youtube
want to get involved
with Girls With Impact,
how can they do that?
JENNIFER OPENSHAW: Oh, so
I want and need all of you
join us at Girls With Impact,
please, boys and girls.
Look it, we are all
in this together.
So you can either--
just help amplify
what we're doing.
Please go to Girls With Impact--
we're going to
send out an email.
You can play a role
in supporting a girl
to go through the training.
You could also, if you
want, mentor a girl.
And we keep it pretty
flexible, not heavy duty
because people are
all over the place.
But it's a great way to
have a personal legacy
and to really join us in
hopefully having a really
big legacy.
I hope you all will.
DANIELLE: Thank you, Jennifer.
We really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]